deserted streets and telltale signs of
Monday's violence in the northern Indian
state of haryana
tensions escalated in the new District
when a religious procession by a
right-wing Hindu group was stopped from
passing through a Muslim majority area
during the standoff houses shops
Vehicles police vans and even ambulances
were touched
several people were killed and injured
police officers among them
a curfew is in place to prevent further
unrest internet services have been
suspended and schools and colleges are
closed the state government says the
violence was engineered
the violence wasn't spontaneous there is
a conspiracy behind this there were
Stones weapons bullets found it seems
there is a mastermind behind this
someone engineered it we will conduct a
detailed investigation and take strict
actions against the people involved in
this
within ours the unrest had spread
threaten strix on Monday night and Imam
was killed and a mosque was set Ablaze
in a suburb of New Delhi known as a
corporate hub
thousands of police and paramilitary
forces have been deployed to maintain
order and public Gatherings have been
restricted in areas surrounding new
this is an unfortunate incident I appeal
to everyone to maintain Brotherhood
strict action will be taken against the
people responsible for inciting violence
in haryana hundreds of families have
fled the haryana home minister says the
situation is under control but for
residents of new District the sense of
unease remains
um
foreign